foreign
this is the Ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the Dollar
Car Rental Studio this is the Ramsay
show it's where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ken Coleman Joy by my
colleague best-selling author Christy
Wright and we are here together today to
take your calls Triple eight eight two
five five two two five it is a free call
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five now of course we'll take your money
calls uh but because Chrissy and I are
here together we're gonna lock arms and
dive in on stuff that we work on every
day and talk about on our shows that are
named after us uh and so we'll talk
about uh the all-important topic of how
slammed everybody feels stressed out
there's not enough time Christie's brand
new book that's available for pre-sale
right now take back your time the
guilt-free Guide to Life bouncil we'll
take those calls you're feeling frazzled
uh guilty about it
she's ready all right I'll just sit back
and listen and and you know just Marvel
and take some notes uh how about a side
business want to start a side business
or you've started one and you need a
little bit of coaching there well she is
a certified business coach all right so
we'll do that uh Hey in my area I'm
trying to help people do work that they
love income and impact how about that oh
how about a job
that actually gets you a bigger shovel
and you actually love doing it uh side
hustle idea Chrissy and I love to
combine on those uh leadership
challenges you're in a situation where
you love the work but you're in a
horrible leadership situation Christy
and I love taking on leadership
questions as well if you want to lead
better so if I cover just about
everything besides money that you and I
like to talk about I think you have the
so what's interesting is for years of
doing this show even when we get money
calls can so often it's actually not a
money question it's a if they think it's
a money question and it ends up being a
relationship issue or they think it's a
money question and it's a job issue or
it's a pricing issue in your business so
uh you can call with whatever question
you have what we're going to do is get
to the root of it whatever that may be
and you're married I'm married we both
have three kids so we can commiserate we
we feel your pain don't we yes you you
tell me the littles are easier I I
believe that your kids are easier either
way we just feel like the problem
somehow has it easier yeah
parenting just is so stinking
isn't it especially when you're
parenting trying to launch something or
in your case uh a book keeping a
business going oh by the way you're in
seminary too listen I don't know you got
two boys take on a lot just so that you
could use your books just so I could
Implement is that what it was I would
love it it feels like maybe you did that
that would be a great marketing play
though I have a lifelong history of this
problem no listen you you have two boys
and a daughter as well but listen for
all the all the boy parents out there
man it's like I don't know where this is
going but I'm excited how many times a
day do the boy moms and dads say what
were you thinking like it's like I
literally don't think their brain works
sometimes but let me just tell you on
behalf of all men and boys you're right
100 let me tell you I walked in my son's
room two nights ago a true story this is
just an example of like how my efforts
to clean or keep it together are just
lost with my children feudal I walk in
his room which was clean like
approximately 3.4 seconds earlier and
there's these like brown wood chips all
over the floor and I look at him and I
go what happened and he looks at me with
a dead straight facing because
I shaved my pet pine cone
of course I did I shaved my pet pine
cone why do you have a pine cone why is
it your pet why did so many questions
man they just bring the outside inside
rocks sticks pine cones acorns my house
is full of this stuff and no matter how
quickly I get rid of it were you mildly
entertained or no
sounds like you weren't I I was so
amused that he said it was such a
straight face like but that was like
what a stupid question you're asking me
Mom yeah Mom pretty awesome I shaved my
pet Pinecone I was like well this is why
I can't have a clean house or nice
things this right here and you know what
my when I share those frustrations my
wife goes just remember before we know
it it's going to be really really quiet
around here oh that's sweet I don't
think that in that moment I just think
pick up the wood chips I need to think
yeah well you don't realize she says
that and I know that she means that and
I go yeah exactly like counting down the
day it's exactly right right where I
walk into a room and the light is off
because no one's in it
there's a novel idea Kelly you know what
I'm talking about you got teens uh there
there is something about it where I have
tried to flip my focus to see often we
we I talk about this in the seasons
actually in the book in the we focus on
the good in our past and the good in the
future but we we miss the good in our
present and so I'll see this the finger
smudges on the window and I think oh
gosh I wish my house clean but I'm gonna
miss those footy pajamas and snuggles so
remember oh this is symbolic of the
season and there's good in that season
so we need we need to focus on the good
no matter what Kelly you were gonna say
something or that I'll walk into a room
and the TV won't be on yeah right yeah
because they just leave the room yeah oh
yeah okay so since we're on this my
number one pet peeves I walk into our
bonus room and the TV's on not a kid
anywhere near it and the uh reclining
chair left open they think they get out
of that and they don't shut the recliner
how do they get out with itself because
they're teenagers and nothing makes
sense nothing makes sense so anyway we
digress but I guess we wanted to share
that so you people know that we feel
your pain if you're struggling we're
struggling in it with you with your time
with your kids with your relationships
your money whatever we're here for you
to empathize and hopefully give you some
advice exactly so how about young
Mitchell I like where we're going here
Mitchell in Minneapolis Minnesota how
can we help
yeah I just have a quick question sure
um so I'm 17.
and I have about 25 000 but I'm not too
exactly sure what to do with it wow good
for you way to go first of all did
someone give you this money or did you
work and save it up
or way to go Mitchell how'd you earn
that money
um right now I'm going to Prime this
electrician and I work on the road come
on you're awesome Mitchell hey when did
you start that program how old were you
uh just apprentice electrician I've only
been doing it for roughly two months are
you in high school still production jobs
yes good for you man that's amazing well
um I got a couple more questions and
then I'll tell you what what you
probably should do with it at your age
and that's being the biggest Factor here
um are you planning to go to college
not necessarily but maybe a community
college okay okay well cool well here my
same whether you go to college or not
because of your age
you were at a very
very transitional not even really
transitional yet but about to be
transitional stage in your life between
18 and 25 26 there's a lot of life
changes that happen there possibly
College whether it's Community College
or undergrad degree or even if you
decide to pursue other school or
specialty school that type of thing
certifications credentials possibly
might want to buy a house possibly might
want to get married and I'm talking
about in this time frame between 17 and
26 or so on so what I would do as
mathematically counterintuitive as as it
may seem as I would just leave it in a
savings account for right now because
what you're going to want to do is
you're going to want to access that
money and the best way to access it is
in a savings account you're going to
want to access it for any of those
things whether it's paying for school
paying for books paying for a house down
payment or whatever but you're doing
awesome just keep saving keep funding
that money and then when you're in your
mid to late 20s in some of these major
life transitions are behind you
hopefully you'll still be debt free at
that point and then you would just begin
to follow the baby steps which at that
point you're going to build a fully
funded emergency fund and uh and
possibly you know start investing in
that type of thing at that point but
right now you're doing awesome hold on
to it for any life changes that might
come your way soon way to go to it way
to go keep pouring on the cash Christy I
love this young man who's in the trades
he's a princess he's made money this
young man is probably going to start a
business he's got options oh he's going
to be a full-time millionaire employing
a lot of people doing great trade work
way to go young man thank you so much
for the call all right she is Christy
Wright I'm Ken Coleman this is the Rams
machine
[Music]
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
thrilled to have you with us as we talk
about your life Christy Wright is my
colleague she joins me here in the
studio I'm Ken Coleman we're thrilled to
be with you at Ramsey personalities we
host shows by our names very creative we
came up with the Christy Wright show and
the Ken Coleman show after just hours
and hours of just unbelievable
brainstorming that's what we came up
with but we're thrilled to have you with
us it is a free call Triple eight eight
two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to Jamie
now in Savannah Georgia Jamie how can we
help
oh
so I have a question I am I have a great
job right now
um but I got a little curious and I
applied for a company
um and they actually accepted me now I
love everything about the job that I'm
doing now and then I'm and
um
uh the my question is do I
leave the job with the company that I
love to go and make more money or do I
stay with the company now even though
there isn't that much of an opportunity
for growth okay that's the issue so it's
never about money it's got to be about
opportunity to move up to climb up the
ladder so it feels like there's a lid
even though this is a great company and
you love the people feels like you got a
lid where you are currently correct
I do because it's like gosh it's a great
place to work
um
but and uh well yeah but it's a small
um family-owned company
um but I don't like corporate either I
hate the HR I hate the like I just I've
never gotten along with corporate I've
always been happy with smaller
businesses and I'm just like well but
I'm also contemplating on this job
because at my age I feel like I'm very
financially behind too so I'm like well
do I just grow up put my big girl pants
on and take this job all right with the
company that I love well I think long
term you're not going to stay at the
company you're currently at you're just
not you know it and I know it so the
question becomes we don't want to be
tempted by money only
uh so the question becomes is this new
job opportunity only about money or
would it put you on the right ladder and
allow you to climb down the road
doing what you want to do
um
doing what I want to do yeah there's the
answer he does yeah that's the thing too
it's like right now I have so many more
like I
do at the at this job now I have more
variety and everything but at this
corporate job I'll pretty much kind of
just be like on a production line for
the year and then I'll move up into a
more advancement type opportunity but
then like I don't have job security with
this new job because they like to hire
contractors and drop people off after
they you know they just like during
covid they fired a lot of people okay
but then like Jamie Jamie you don't want
this job yeah you keep trying to talk
yourself you're telling me why you don't
want this job we don't even have to
answer this for you you already know the
answer you don't want it no and so you
pass
you pass here's why but I feel like it
feels so stupid though because like as
far as like the the you know as far as
like the money goes it's just let me
break you can pursue that somewhere else
in another small business this is not
the only opportunity to make more money
so let me just tell you something yeah
you need to stay where you are until you
find the next step towards the thing you
actually want to do the kind of work you
want to do which I think you're doing a
good bit of right now at this smaller
company but you are limited so you want
to stay and say no to the pay now here's
why and I want to break this down
Christy I hear this all the time on the
Ken Coleman show it feels so
counterintuitive it feels she almost
feels like I know Christy you're right
because you you called her out on it but
she's going but I feel like I'd be
stupid right to turn down a bigger
paycheck and I understand that that is a
psychological hurdle but here's the
reality
she's gonna take if she takes that job
she's on that assembly line maybe six
weeks and she don't even make it to
advance with because she's miserable so
in this situation Jamie let's let's say
no to the good so we can say yes to the
best and I think for now it's okay I'm
gonna pass on the paycheck only but now
I'm gonna get serious as Christy said
there are other smaller company
environments where you can do the kind
of work that you love and grow and make
the money so this is one of those deals
where we have to say no to the shiny
object because it's not going to be that
shiny after that the high of the
paycheck wears off not only that but
let's just put the paycheck aside for
just a second even talk about the
opportunity because I love how you were
asking her about that if we're not
careful and I see a lot of people do
this even if they can let go of the
paycheck piece of it the idea of
progress promotion a higher position
forward advancement whatever is so
appealing because we are wired for
progress as humans for sure but what
happens is we say yes to the position or
promotion and don't realize that we're
making progress in a company we hate so
you're just advancing in an environment
you don't want to be climb in a ladder
you don't want to be on
then they call you and go oh they call
me and they go well I got stuck in this
thing oh really you got yourself stuck
right you walked right into it right but
here's what's so great about this and
Jamie I want you to see this in the in
the moment that you're into making this
decision this is an awesome position to
be in because you've realized you might
want something different and you can
begin to pursue that in the right
company in the right position with more
pay it's not this one but it has maybe
lit something in you to go hey I might
want to start looking for something new
and that's an awesome thing to learn
about yourself and it's going to take
you down this path which king Coleman
walks you through with his path you're
starting to get more clear about what
you want and that's going to be great
information as you pursue this yeah I
want to uh I gotta I gotta I gotta share
this with you Christy New York Times
headline today workers in demand have a
new demand of their own a career path
mark Ray was working at a concession
stand at a movie theater when the
pandemic hit last year the movie theater
of course shut down he loses his job but
instead of looking for another other
low-wage job Ray seeks a different path
so he goes and gets a class and basic
technology business skills completed it
and gets a job at a fast growing online
company
he started this last March
working in a customer service and tech
support job now he makes 55 000 a year
compared with seventeen thousand dollars
at a movie theater and here's it made me
think about what you just said his quote
in the New York Times said the pandemic
weirdly was an opportunity
and this job is a huge stepping stone
for me I have I've seen more and more of
this that the pandemic forced change on
people it makes him a question status
quo yeah and so now you go well wait a
second where else do I want to make
change if this amount of change has been
forced on me and I didn't die because
change is so horrible sure where else
can I make changes and when you said
that it made me think of this of this
story I shared earlier today on my show
but we've got 40 of of workers that were
in the nation's hospitality industry
saying they're not going back yeah yeah
you know why because they're going I'm
going to Pivot yeah well and you make a
good point too because whether it is the
pandemic or some other life change or
whatever that forces you to look at your
life differently when you have that
moment you start to it's like this light
bulb moment ago oh I didn't know I
wanted that I didn't know I wanted a job
that had XYZ or made by you know in in
Jamie's case I didn't know I wanted a
company where it made more money and had
more advancement until I once I was
aware of it well now I can't not pursue
it and that awareness whether it's from
the pandemic in that example in the New
York Times or Jamie's example there's
something really powerful when we
realize that we want more because then
it activates us to pursue it versus just
surviving keeping your head above water
going to a job you hate making 17 000 a
year man when something wakes you up to
more it's it ignites you to go pursue it
you see that all the time with the
ladies you coach a business Boutique and
helping them start a business they're
the ones that make it yes when it's like
a more thing it's a lot of thing it's
like oh yeah you know what had I heard
the coolest quote from a woman last week
I ran into her and she said I think
she's actually here at the the office
she said I came to your business
Boutique conference which if y'all don't
know we do a conference every October
we're doing it again this October 14th
through the 16th but she said I came to
your conference and I her quote I didn't
know I had a business in me yeah and you
showed me I had one in me and now I'm
running my business and I love it oh my
God and you're going all over that is so
cool that this moment showed you
something you wanted something more for
your life and then you went after it I
love that
I open every day on the show you were
created to feel unique unique role you
were needed you must do it I love that I
didn't know I had a business in me oh
she's got purpose she's got a why I love
it really good stuff all right hey she's
Chrissy Wright I'm Ken Coleman it's a
free call Triple eight eight two five
five two two five I just feel like
somebody needs to call today
we're sitting here for you come on let's
go this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Kim
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Chrissy Wright and we are taking your
calls this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five eight eight two
five five two two five auto insurance
companies love to play the game where
they see just how high they can jack up
your rates for no reason that's always
fun isn't it well the good news is it's
not hard to beat them at their own game
all you got to do is check up on your
policy every year or two and make sure
you're getting the best price for your
covers that's it and what's even easier
and not to mention free is that you can
hire one of our endorsed local provider
or EOP insurance agents to do this for
you elps are independent agents who shop
to find you the best coverage free of
charge they won't excuse me they don't
work for one insurance company meaning
they've got the freedom to shop as many
policies as it takes to find the one
that's right for you don't sit back back
while your insurance company raises your
rates text the word Auto to 33789 that's
auto text that to 33789 and put a
trusted ELP agent on your team text Auto
to three three
seven eight nine all right Christy I see
here we've got Matthew and Rachel on the
line in Frederick Maryland for a debt
free screen Matthew and Rachel hello
hello how's it going guys
going good so you are debt free all
right tell us how much did you pay off
we paid off 57 000 in 14 months Wow way
to go and uh how much income what was
the income range during the time
one about one 110 000 to 125 000.
awesome what do you guys do
oh yeah what are we doing we're having a
baby
that is not even what we were asking but
that is even better answer
congratulations you guys yeah it was my
fault I should have said what do you
guys do for a living that would have
been a little clearer well
congratulations I'm so used to getting
that do question I'm a general manager
at a small retail business awesome and I
work at my family's construction
management business awesome well
congratulations on the baby is this your
first
it is oh congratulations you guys uh I I
feel like we're about five weeks away
now oh my gosh you're so close oh there
they oh that's beautiful y'all are so
cute that's amazing I feel like I should
tell you on behalf of uh Christy and I
this better be positive or I'm gonna cut
you off it's very positive okay that you
need to get some rest yeah some extra
naps to store up before the little one
arrives that's very exciting oh my gosh
well how cool you guys that y'all paid
off your debt before your first baby is
here tell us the story let's go back to
14 months ago what happened that got you
on this journey
so truthfully uh we got engaged and
bought a house and you know as I'm
sitting up one night uh I'm thinking
about you know my debt our debt you know
Dave with with the pronouns changing it
from from mine to hours
um and just really thinking about the
future and and really truthfully this
moment of having a baby came into my
mind of you know just my
responsibilities if Rachel got pregnant
and maybe wasn't able to work and and
just to not have that burden
um it has been such a relief to be able
to really focus on the future and being
a good provider for our family so that
kind of started it and then it took some
convincing to get Rachel on board oh
okay so so I want to hear that story but
before you do what was the what kind of
debt was it
so the debt was uh your typical stuff
that you guys probably hear every day
credit card debt uh two car loans and
student loans okay all right so you have
this light bulb moment when you're
engaged you're thinking about the future
thinking about Rachel a future baby all
the things you're like we got to get
this cleaned up Rachel you weren't
having it tell me about it
my husband but I was
I would really drastically change our
way of life and like how we were living
and like be much more stingy sure and
you know I'm the spender in this couple
I do that without you saying it Rachel
you know I like to go shopping and so I
was nervous about that like how it was
going to change things I didn't want to
I didn't want to compromise our
lifestyle right now for a future that I
couldn't see yet yeah yeah that was kind
of why I was how long did it take for
you to go from that to okay I'm all in
not very long how long would you say it
took me uh I would say it was all not
necessarily immediate but I'm in
business development and sales so he had
a good pitch yeah I like this he knew
how to present it right all right so
let's go let's stay there Rachel so you
were afraid you're gonna have to adjust
your lifestyle and I'm looking at fifty
seven thousand dollars paid off in 14
months you clearly did so what how did
you change your lifestyle
I mean honestly yeah the big thing was
less eating out because we were so used
to doing that and so we have but having
a house together now we were living
together like that helped because early
on we weren't you know we were living
far apart so every time we would see
each other we would be going out to eat
so we changed our lifestyle in that way
which was a good thing
um and honestly like my husband put
together a wonderful budget spreadsheet
and he was able to show me and teach me
like where our money was going so I had
more of an understanding of how much I
was spending because before I met him I
was never tracking what I was spending
yeah because I had no idea awesome and
so then when I saw it in front of me I
was like oh I guess I don't really need
to be going to get my nail stuff so
often or like I was able to visually see
how I could change things without it
being
it's too drastic yeah that makes sense
you know I don't know that we've ever
run a study or correlation between the
spouses that are the more reluctant one
whether it takes them five seconds or
you know five years to get on board and
them being the spender because I'm I
would be willing to bet 100 of the
spouses that don't want to get aboard
are the Spinners I'm the spender because
you don't you don't want to adjust your
lifestyle it's hard to make sacrifice
you're like spending is fun budgets seem
boring I don't want to do this I bet
there's a direct correlation there
Rachel of the spouses that are the
Spenders that also might be the ones
that are a little more reluctant but
you're right because when you can see it
you can see oh wow it's not so much that
it's going to take away all the fun
forever it's just a lifestyle change
with more intentionality in the short
term in order to get to your goal and
you guys did that that is that is
awesome okay now she can do her nails as
much as she wants that's right good move
Matthew hey well played well played who
are your biggest cheerleaders
uh who are our cheerleaders yeah
so truthfully it was a lot of it was
each other
um I think in in the beginning you know
when we told our family and friends I
think
can you hear us yeah we lost you for a
second but you're back told your family
sorry about that uh in the beginning I
think we were what I was saying was we
were our biggest supporters and
cheerleaders yeah but you know our our
family supported us but I think there
was a lot of questions like how are you
guys even gonna do this right
um but then when I started to explain
you know it it became a lot more clear
and I think you know our families have
all been on board and our friends and
you know the more we talk about it it's
kind of funny where we tell people about
our plane and they say oh wow I've heard
of Dave Ramsey we're on this planet or
we're on this plan
um so I think it's just opened up
opening up the conversation
um has really helped a lot of our
friends kind of start their own so I
think we're big advocates for it because
it works yeah a living example that it
works yeah we hear that a lot when when
someone gets debt free their family
their friends they start asking well how
did you do it even the family and
friends that were skeptical at first
what is the uh what's the secret if
someone's listening right now near on
the fence on if they should really go
all in on this debt snowball debt free
plan what what's the secret what made it
possible for you guys
these prayer patience and persistence
okay well let's write that down I love
it yeah we stepped to see was like you
got he
patient you got you got me like
but at the end of the day like my
parents instilled this in me too that
God will provide and we just have to
continue to pray that he has his plan
and that he'll reveal his plan to us if
we just keep I love it doing what we're
doing you guys are awesome yeah all
right so here we go we've got Matthew
and Rachel on the line in Frederick
Maryland it was about prayer patience
and persistence 57 000 and 14 months
going from 110 000 to 125 000 Matthew
and Rachel let's hear a debt-free screen
all right we're ready three two one
we're dead free
[Applause]
yes this is three p's hey that's what
you need for anything in life let's just
someone Stitch that on a pillow
everything in anything in life
everything's better with alliteration
I'd like to point that out you remember
we're done Matthew three p's that'll
work really great couple that's what
it's all about they did it and you can
do it don't move more Randy show coming
right up
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
thrilled to have you with us as we talk
about your life Christy Wright is my
co-host I'm Ken Coleman with Ramsey
personalities and we are here for you to
take your calls Triple eight eight two
five five two two five eight eight two
five five two two five I've got to
mention this really quick because this
is kind of a unique situation really for
Ramsey Solutions as we put out more and
more content and it affects us we both
have books out right now yes for
pre-sale we so I'm going to talk about
yours if you'll talk about mice is it
fair yes but I think people need to know
we've never done this as a company ever
that we have released two books at the
same time which is really exciting and
it just shows the growth and the demand
out there for getting help in these
different areas they they complement
each other they're different messaging
but but equally important Christy's book
is take back your time the guilt-free
Guide to Life balance and this comes
from your own life which is always the
best when you're trying to manage so
much you're a successful businesswoman
coach author uh broadcaster oh by the
way three kiddos pubs a dog all the
things right and the reality is is that
this is a book that is really helping
people see that that balance isn't this
you know this mysterious thing and it's
going to be all perfect it's really my
favorite thing is it's about doing the
right thing at the right time and I
think there's so much freedom in that
concept there's so much more in it but
it's a fabulous book and it's available
for pre-sale right now
ramseysolutions.com if you pre-order it
it's all kinds of amazing goodies this
is what we do we give people a ton of
free stuff including the audiobook and
the e-book and all the things and the
book actually hits uh really soon yeah
it's so September 14th is the launch and
then here's what's cool if you buy them
pre-order and you get the audiobook an
ebook and all that good stuff a private
Facebook group with me and all that you
also get a ticket to my live event in
September and here's here's a fun fact I
shared this this week it's on September
16th so it's two days after launch that
also is my daughter's second birthday so
you want to talk about living out living
out life balance in real life please
tell me that that little sweet princess
will show up on stage at some point
maybe for a dance party she may or may
not be making an appearance I'm like
flat in the room how can I work her into
this all right I love that so really
exciting so yeah but is it you're right
it's just such a struggle and so we're
trying to bring a message of freedom to
a an area where people feel guilty but
what's interesting is I think this has
been really fun for us to release these
books at the same time because this is a
topic I've talked about for 10 years
your book can from paycheck to purpose
this is all about finding your dream job
the path to work that you love you've
been talking about that even longer how
long have you been talked how long have
you been coaching people in their career
uh eight to ten years started doing it
in Atlanta before I got here just
because it was something that I I this
book is born out of my own Journey where
I thought politics was my future and at
the age of 33 realized it wasn't and
then what did I do did I blow it did I
waste my life up to this point how do I
figure it out and then through
self-reflection and some you know really
great guides around me uh learned how to
get clear which is the first stage of
the seven stages and the rest of the
stages really came through my journey to
get into broadcast a very tough field as
you know and just kind of work your way
through it you know it's interesting
there are people listening right now and
they know they need this book and so
we'll tell them how to get it but there
are some people listening right now that
don't know that they need it and and
here's what I want you to speak to
really quickly I want you to speak to
the person that has never ever enjoyed
their work they have always just done
either what was available or what they
need to do to get by they collected a
paycheck so you know Ken you know this
from anything if you've never
experienced something it's very
difficult to believe it exists it's very
difficult to uh to explain to someone or
make someone believe that is so
disheartened about work that you could
actually look forward to Monday yeah you
could actually have fun at your job and
get paid for I want you to speak to that
person that does not believe that's out
there really quickly yeah so it's very
simple if you use what you do best your
talent and you do work you love I Define
that as passion and you produce results
that matter deeply to you there's a
value connection that's Mission when
you're in alignment Talent passion and
Mission
it's unbelievable you got the juices I
like to say because you just you're
you're operating obviously with talent
but you actually love the work and the
result matters deeply that's all it is
and when that happens for many people
they've never experienced that they're
largely treating a job as something I do
to get a paycheck yeah and that's why we
chose the title from paycheck to purpose
we want people to realize that they can
make the income they need bigger shovel
get out of debt hello uh fund the future
of your kids great trips whatever but
also do work that matters deeply to you
you and I both get to do that yeah we're
good at the work but it's not about
Talent right it's really about loving
the work and producing result that when
you go home at the end of the day in a
tough day and you go I I produce results
that matter to me yeah and therein lies
the significant contribution you were
created to make well and there are some
people too that they're not aware that
that is in them but it is it and you I
hear you say this all the time when you
talk to people so inside of each of us
is that Talent is that mission is that
purpose and it may be dormant it may
have collected dust for a couple decades
but it's still in there and I've seen
you coach people I've watched videos of
you coaching people and when you peel
away the layers and ask these questions
that help them tap into that their eyes
fill with tears because they are then
like we were talking about a minute ago
aware of something they wanted they
didn't even know they wanted and
something that's possible that they
didn't even know it's possible so and I
love that in this book though you don't
just you don't just give them the
inspiration of like rah-rah you can do
it you can you know have a per you walk
them through very tactical steps of step
one step two step three and so on of how
to pursue it it's very tactical it's not
enough to know what it is you got to do
it uh the reality is is that we were
created to contribute so it's the seven
stages and uh really really excited
about it from people to realize that
there is in fact purpose in your work
not just a j-o-b and so fun stuff fun
times realitysolutions.com there it is
all the goodies there uh same deal get
it for 20 bucks you get all kinds of
goodies the audiobook ebook same kind of
deal there and so I get both of them I I
think that they're wonderful tools and
so there you go we're really proud of
the work because we we have lived it and
I think that's the one thing I want to
buy something from somebody that's
actually walked in it not just kind of
well I just learned this Theory yep and
uh so really really good stuff there uh
the number to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we're talking about this and I and I and
I want to stay on this topic because I
think there are a lot of people right
now that are listening and they hear us
talk a little bit about you know the
purpose side of things but they're not
thinking purpose in working for someone
else they're going
like you you talked about before lady
came up to you recently said I didn't
realize until I came to business
Boutique that there was a business in me
and a lot of people want to work for
themselves we're seeing more of this
because of the pandemic right a lot more
we're also seeing an interesting wave
coming from the the mosaics that's
called the Gen Z if you will that they
want to start businesses largely right
out of school or even out of high school
um
that why that purpose that solving a
problem uh how do you help people
identify the business idea
like we do with anything here so I
actually have a course I created on that
but the very short version of the answer
is start with what you have so your
skills your strengths and your stuff
your skills or your education
credentials things you're trained to do
your strengths are just things you're
good at you've never been trained but
you're you're good at it and your stuff
what do you have around you to already
work with and and this these three areas
are going to be great starting point to
inspire you to brainstorm things that
you can do but the great thing about
starting a business from home or a side
business or freelance work is there's
not a lot of pressure when you do it the
way that I teach you to which is to
start small and grow slow because you're
not spending a ton of money you're not
you know going and getting an education
this thing that's not even proven you're
just gonna try it it it that might mean
you're gonna post on Facebook hey I'm
gonna do some freelance writing if you
know of anyone let me know it might be
emailing family and friends hey I think
I'm going to start Fitness coaching or
you know whatever that thing is and it
starts so simple and small but what's
interesting is I love how Dave Ramsey
says business is a conversation with the
marketplace when you put something out
there the marketplace responds and they
say hey yes we need this or more of this
less of this and you begin to engage and
then that informs what you're supposed
to do you know more of what you're
supposed to do by engaging with the
market but if you wait till it's perfect
to do anything or take any step you'll
never do anything so so yeah start with
what you have your skills your strengths
your stuff let that inspire you to
brainstorm things that you could do from
home on your own terms make extra money
call your own shots just tell people hey
I'm doing this I'm building cabinets
anybody wants some cabinets you know you
don't have to have this giant business
plan I love what you're saying just get
Scrappy get out there and start showing
people your work Scrappy wins over
sophisticated every time we think we
have to be so sophisticated no just get
Scrappy yeah just get Scrappy make it
work by the way Scrappy the Dog remember
him cartoons Saturday morning you don't
remember Scrappy great great little
cartoon character look him up hey I want
to thank our producer Ben Hill our
associate producer and call Scooter
Ellie Daniel my colleague and co-host is
our Christie Wright but mostly you
America thank you so much for joining us
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
have a friend or a family member that
needs a daily dose of Ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
Ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the Ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the Dollar
Car Rental Studio this is the Ramsey
Show it's where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life I'm
Ken Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Christy Wright and we're thrilled to be
together today as we take your calls
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five we're here for you if
you've got a question we're going to
walk you through it I promise you uh
there is hope there is a clear path for
you to move forward and so we are
excited to have your call Triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
get it started this hour in Cincinnati
Ohio Cynthia joins us there Cynthia how
can we help Hi how are you guys we're
having a blast what's going on awesome
yeah well I'm the I am the nerd in my
family and I am married to a very
reasonable free spirit and I like this
setup
um he sprung on me about six weeks ago
that at some point in the near future he
would like to buy a used Ford car I mean
the twenty thousand dollar range okay
and I just kind of want to see if we're
in a position that we can do that for
him well walk us through where you are
and why you might be a little nervous
about it well because I'm the nerd
that's why I'm nervous yeah he's 64. I'm
50. so he's uh close to retirement about
a four-year plan our assets are in the
950 000 range wow and
um I think we can do it I'm pretty sure
we can I just want to oh what baby step
are you on uh we're like on seven we
don't have a mortgage I'm gonna let you
take over here woman to woman Chrissy
take it away Cynthia you already know
what I'm gonna say yeah they are almost
millionaires you're on baby step seven
and you're asking about a used twenty
thousand dollar car for fun for your
husband who's almost retired Cynthia
what am I gonna say
you're gonna say yes yes I am now listen
I love that you acknowledged up front
that you're the nerd and so you're
nervous like you connected those it's
not on the nerve and then in a separate
conversation you're nervous it's like no
you're you're nervous because you're the
nerd nerds are just nervous y'all are
just nervous all the time you don't like
to spend money Matt can want something
Matt's the nerd in our marriage and he
can want something and we can have the
money for it and he still does not like
letting go of money and that's a
wonderful gift because y'all are on baby
step seven Because of You Cynthia listen
you are the ones that kept you all
focused and on track so well done but
listen you did that hard work and you've
been responsible so that you can enjoy
it and so yes can you afford it yes
should you buy it yes all the answers to
all your questions are yes absolutely
a couple thousand yes yes and can I just
add one thing Christie's giving you
great advice can I just add one little
thing would you please enjoy it with him
would you go babe I can't wait to go
shopping for the 22 000 sports car we're
crazy
I didn't say that you were driving it I
said you just ride with him and enjoy it
as a couple you can ride yeah that's
awesome Cynthia you're great thank you
so much what a fun question yeah those
are the kind of calls you want because
you want to show this is what life is
like when you do save up and you're on
baby step seven and you have no debt
yeah you can spend your money please do
please like no one else so that later
you can live and give like no one else
so the live is a sports car have some
fun and you're giving his way giving
away away as well so the wonderful
wonderful call and and I I think it's
going to be really fun for to see them
take some pictures share it really enjoy
it Cynthia this is a big deal for your
hubs too he's worked hard and this is
gonna be a lot of fun all right let's go
to Chicago Illinois next and Sean is
there Sean how can we help
how are you guys doing we're having a
blast what's going on oh that's that's
awesome so I had a question about moving
out so I'm 23 years old I actually never
been on my own I've actually always goes
away uh with my parents and um so far it
was it was going well I'm working
full-time now
um but I just wanted to ask you based on
my financial situation would I be able
to move out uh with the rising and
Central class physical Department tell
us your financial how much money did you
make yes yeah yeah so
um I currently make around 56 000
annually so after taxes and 401ks and
benefits I think around like 40ish
um I do want to bring this up but I did
have student loans I had it I graduated
last year
um and I had student loans and they
wouldn't let me in the face I did buy a
car for 28 000 in November but as of
June I paid both of those off so
um and I'm completely debt free so I
just wanted to know
yeah thank you thank you very much so I
just wanted to know what the rising
rental costs it's just a little
concerning about me going on my own I've
never had that experience and
um I just need to have like confidence
whether I could actually afford it or
not so what do you guys think yeah Sean
so because you've never lived on your
own it's scary to you but that's not
going to be a reason that's going to
stop you because you're a man okay
you're not a boy you're not a guy you're
not a dude you're a man that makes a
really good income that's debt free you
should not be living at home and so yeah
so now how you go about it totally up to
you you could find a really
um maybe a family friend that has a
rental property and so you know the
landlord you get a roommate you you ease
yourself into this transition in any way
that you want to but absolutely you
should move out the rental costs are not
a even a factor for me because what
you're going to do is you're going to
find something you can afford because
moving out is that important it's not
like oh well I'll move out if I can find
something you know that that's in my
desired area and XYZ all this criteria
no no you're going to move out because
you're a man that's debt free with a
good income that has no reason to be
living at home whatsoever and so that
we're going to go ahead and make that
definitive and then within that
assumption we're going to say okay now
what can we afford on your income so
you're going to look for you know either
an apartment or a house get feel free to
get a roommate I've actually in my 20s
when I was single I had multiple
roommates some of which I knew and some
of which I was paired with and didn't
know and some were more awesome than
others for sure but all of it's a
learning experience and none of it's
forever so
um if you want to if you want to split
costs in that way get a roommate you can
go about that but absolutely I think
that this is this is a necessity for you
and what it's going to do for you Sean
aside from relieve your fears of being
on your own is it's going to give you a
completely different level of dignity
and Independence and confidence that is
going to pour over in every aspect of
your life from your job up to dating to
goals and your finances I mean this is
so so important for you so yes yes you
should move out and you figure out how
to make the finances work if you need to
make more money or find a cheaper
apartment roommate you do that because
it's it's time to go yeah and Sean I you
know this is this is almost a silly fear
and you have to own that it's silly
because you've just paid off a bunch of
debt you know how to be responsible with
your money so I don't know what your
specific fear is but you need to own it
I'm afraid that I can't afford it that's
silly unless you try to rent a penthouse
in downtown Chicago but Christy just
laid it out for you and uh so you've got
this man there's nothing to be afraid of
be responsible and you're going to be
okay fly little bird fly I also want to
point out that Christy don't you let him
call you a little bird no go back to it
you're a man I want to give him like a
man I was gonna point out that you just
told him man up in your really nice way
I was like Wow ouch
older sister Christy just put a boot to
his hind end I think he's packing as we
speak I can hear the tape ripping right
now good stuff hey she's Christy Wright
I'm Ken Coleman this is the Ramsey Show
don't go anywhere more coming right up
[Music]
oh
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to Pure Talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just thirty
dollars a month get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the Irish family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to Pure
Talk just go to puretalk.com and enter
the promo code Ramsay to save 50 off
your first month Pure Talk simply
smarter Wireless
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back America you are listening
to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman
joined by my colleague Christy Wright
and before we went to the break we took
a call from a young man who was uh 23.
uh just paid off a bunch of debt uh
makes about 40 40ish a year his words
yeah and take home and he was uh
debating whether or not it was the right
move for him to move out and live on his
own and you told him at least three
times you're a man you're a man and then
and then you had a really funny thought
you're like oh I wish I'd told him this
so I thought I gotta tee you up to tell
her well we ran out of time but here's
what I was gonna say if you won't do it
for you moving out is what I was
referring to if you want to do it for
you do it for the potential of a future
spouse because let's say you meet some
really awesome girl and she's like where
do you live and you're like at home with
Mom and Dad that's not cool nobody
thinks that's cool that's not cool in
anybody's book so if you want to do it
for you do it for the potential of an
awesome girl you might meet hey I mean
we see people get out of decks like man
I wasn't really motivated for me but but
maybe for my kids I feel like I need to
do it or whatever even if it's for
someone else I don't really care why you
do the right thing just do the right
thing I don't care if someone else
motivates you just do the right thing
for whatever reason why you were saying
that I had the image of Failure to
Launch with Matthew McConaughey and
Sarah Jessica Parker I was talking to
him fantastic that exact movie yeah I
was gonna say get yourself Jessica
you're trying to get him out I I want to
say get out of the house I think your
version was fly little bird but either
way you you gotta go if it's a gentle
small bird or me shoving you out you
gotta go it's time to go oh so much fear
around money uh if you're struggling
with money it's easy to tell yourself
that you'll deal with it later or you'll
start fresh in the new year but later
rolls around you still feel out of
control stop
decide right now
that this is the last month that you'll
ever worry about money again if you do
we want to help that's why for this
month only we're knocking thirty dollars
off the 12-month membership
to our most impactful life-changing
money products with the Ramsay Plus
Membership you get access to Financial
Peace University our step-by-step plan
to save money pay off debt
and build wealth plus you get the
premium version of our budgeting tool
every dollar to help you put that plan
into action you deserve a life free of
monthly payments
and constant money stress start your
free trial of Ramsay plus today by
texting trial to 33789 that's trial text
that to three three seven eight nine
let's go to Austin Texas now Sarah joins
us Sarah how can we help
hi there how are you
um so I worked the past five years with
a non-profit that I love passionate
about their missions people culture are
great there's plenty of work flexibility
and they're also a leader in an industry
feel better love which is Women's Health
but for the past months I've been
looking into roles in the private sector
because I wanted to get better
compensated and I just didn't see
opportunity for advancement and
promotion in that organization so I
recently got an offer from a firm to
join as a consultant in an area of
expertise which is just focused on
health it would be a really big shower
about like 70 percent lower wow salary
and the benefits are pretty good the
hiring manager who essentially recruited
or poached me seems very short Affair
and would allow me to work from Health
flexibility but for some reason there's
part of me that's you know hesitant to
take it the company has a reputation
definitely for long hours and test
stress and you know overloaded completed
responsibilities and there's a little
bit of ambiguity in my projects or
responsibilities and I've taken a title
cut too
so while I'm excited about the salary
after the subject is still just holding
me back I don't know it's just what it
is everyone around me says take it you
know I'm crazy you do know what it is
you just laid it out pretty beautifully
so here's what I would tell you since
you were recruited this this hiring
manager came to you
um I think it's a secondary conversation
I think it's one more conversation and
you got to do this humility uh and it's
all about posture your body posture the
tone of your voice but you go Hey listen
I'm excited about this I've heard some
things about the culture here
and I I don't see that with you
um but I've heard some things about the
culture I'd like to ask you to address
so you didn't accuse here you just said
I've heard some things I'd love for you
to address it that's the first step the
second thing I want you to do is is talk
about the ambiguity hey I'd like to ask
a few more questions don't say what
you've told me about my job is ambiguous
what you want to say is hey I've got a
few more questions here I think that's
the grown-up way to do that I think
you've got a wonderful spirit about you
I think if you stay humble there and
watch how you you know handle yourself
with the words you use and Body Language
uh I think a healthy leader is going to
answer those concerns I would not walk
away yet but I think you have to listen
to those concerns I think those are all
legitimate things but uh to hear that
I'm just curious where'd you hear that
what's the reputation where are you
getting that
well it's just these these types of
firms have a reputation for a lot of
stress and I've seen on like glass doors
places like that that you know it is
definitely high stress and high stakes
business yeah but I've also heard that
Christy Wright was Dave's daughter and
that's a rumor too nobody goes on
Glassdoor to sing praises yeah that's
just nobody happy nobody happy with
their position goes on Glassdoor so let
me let me I want to jump in on one thing
Sarah because I I hear a little bit in
your voice that was me about 13 years
ago okay I worked for a non-profit for
three years coming out of college I
believed that in order to do work that
matters you had to do work in non-profit
okay that's what I believed as a 22 year
old I thought I thought all the
for-profit companies are bad evil greedy
all the non-profit companies are good
holy care about people so I want to do
work that mattered so I went and worked
in a non-profit after burning out
working 80 hours a week not making
hardly any money I felt called to do
something different but I was so nervous
address to move outside the nonprofit
world because of my beliefs about these
cultures now I set that up to set you up
to say
are these companies really bad or do you
maybe have some underlying beliefs about
what the corporate world represents not
necessarily that you know this company's
bad yeah
yeah oh I had this I think my long-term
goal is to become a
recognized like expert and consulted for
Women's Health like I love helping women
especially and
um but I've never taken the pledge and
you know actually yeah I've done that so
I'm wondering like maybe I did do I
stick to my current job or have
flexibility in time to start something
on the side or maybe take this job make
some good money and then you know go and
start my own thing Sarah volunteers sir
yes Kirsty gave you great perspective I
want to go back to exactly what I told
you you've got to sit down with this
leader and you've got some you don't
even really have reputation stuff that
you've heard so I think you just
addressed the uh the the work hours
expectations flexibility and some of the
things that you have already said I'm
not 100 sure about my my job description
and what's expected of me uh just just
have that conversation and then trust
your gut you know what else you can do
Sarah when you ask some questions
whether it's the hiring manager or if
you're able to even ever meet with
potential your other co-workers or
managers other people that are in the in
the company when you ask questions you
can ask questions in a really
interesting way that get you the answer
you want and so you can ask a question
like this okay I've got two questions
for you one is what's your favorite part
about working here and what's your least
favorite
because everyone has one everyone I have
a favorite thing about hearing my least
favorite about her everybody has that
about every company in the world but
that might give you insights if they say
hey we work 80 hours a week okay it's a
high stress environment that may
actually in a in a creative way find out
what you want to find another one
information yeah I tell people all the
time on the show ask the question what
describe the type of person that wins in
this company I like that that's
just and again but here's the thing I
think you've identified what you need to
talk about uh but I will tell you I
don't think you have any really concrete
evidence that you need to be worried
about uh but but go at it that way and
then let the answer come back your way
and then then decide but the fact that
this is uh work you want to do and this
puts you on the ladder in the women's
health space from an expertise
standpoint
I it feels really really good to me but
I also want you to go back one more time
but if you feel good after going back
this to me is a no-brainer the extra
money is is gravy uh and Christy again
that's what you and I we both preach
this yep the other day money is never
gonna be
the ultimate reason why you stay at a
place it's got to be meaning and uh so
there you go great stuff uh thank you so
much Sarah excited for you by the way uh
you're on the precipice of something
really really exciting out there thank
you so much for the call all right she
is Christy Wright I'm Ken Coleman this
is the Ramsey Show we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
all right America welcome back this is
the Ramsey show where America talks
about their life and their money I'm Ken
Coleman joined by my colleague Christy
Wright we are here taking your calls to
sour it is a free phone call Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and I look out over there Christine
on the debt free stage in the lobby is
Lindsay hello Lindsay hi how are you I'm
good how are you good so you're debt
free huh I am where are you from uh
Sacramento California oh wow did you fly
or drive we flew okay very nice and you
guys we'll learn more about the big crew
over there I see a nice cheering section
for you absolutely all right so give us
the numbers here how much debt did you
pay off okay so um in total it was 24
360.36 awesome to the penny 36 Cents and
how long did that take so overall it
took me um 17 and a half months
um I had gotten divorced last year moved
home and so that became just my debt
um so yeah in total 17 and a half months
but because I had gone into store mode I
um you know obviously was just making
minimum payments once I got to push play
after getting a full-time job took me 13
and a half months to complete everything
okay and what was the range of income
um it was about 27 000 um up to 37 000.
wow what do you do uh well I'm finally
back down to just one job um I'm a head
cashier oh nice yeah fantastic so I
think we heard a little bit about what
made this happen here uh give us a
little bit more of the back story there
did you know about Dave Ramsey Ramsey
Solutions this whole idea of financial
peace I did um actually it started with
my brother-in-law he um had I'm not sure
how he found it but he had kind of
started us all on this journey him um my
sister got out of debt and then got my
parents on it they've gotten themselves
out of debt except for their house I
unfortunately did not pay as close of
attention initially that I should have
um it uh my actual actually my ex and I
had started
um we'd gone through financial peace
together a couple of years ago and then
the divorce happened and so then it was
now up to me to finish so it's been a
long journey but it's been super worth
it well talk a little bit about those
early stages when you were finally
sitting down to look at the numbers and
what you what that you were responsible
for talk about how you got yourself just
motivated and excited to attack this
attack this debt and really work the
plan not just like hear it in theory
like you were saying you'd heard before
but like actually do something different
why was it different this time
um this time was my sister
um she had had a very big heart to heart
talk with me in January of this year
um and she had just given me you know
helping me set goals
um to kind of get through the year and
get through my debt we realized that I
was not focusing enough on my debt I was
trying to stretch my money too thin and
so she we had kind of agreed okay I need
to get a second job so I can get this
done with I wanted to do more things
with my dad I'd love to you know spoil
my nephew and I couldn't with that
looming over my head so she kind of
helped me with that and that's really
what changed was I got the second job
worked a bunch of hours and
just I got as it got closer and closer I
saw the light at the end of the tunnel I
ended up actually getting in
um right at the beginning of July I got
a full-time job I'd gotten paid from
that and realized I had the money in my
account wow and so I just I came home
from work actually from my second job I
was coming home from work that morning
and I'd come home told my dad I'm like
oh my gosh I think I can do this right
now wow so we double checked my numbers
make sure that I was you know I was
going to be fine financially
um after that and so I just yeah I sent
in the payment and that was that how big
was the payment uh last one was just
under 3 000. oh wow how does it feel now
weird
but no it feels amazing it's been about
a month that I've been debt free and I I
don't I think this kind of helps it feel
more surreal I'm still waiting for my
car title to get to me in the mail
because that was the last debt that I
had
um but it feels amazing to just I mean
that financial piece that is a real
thing I love that I can not have to
worry about where my money is yeah well
and especially for you in this season of
life you are you are giving yourself a a
clean slate a fresh start a new chapter
in every area of your life and money is
just a piece of it but man the freedom
that you feel because you don't have
that debt hanging over you so now when
you start to look at what do you want to
do for work or what goals do you want to
set or what does this new chapter look
like you don't have any of that dragging
you down you've got all the options in
the world that's amazing what's the
secret what do you think was so key to
help you stick with it and do it the
budget okay I know everybody says that
but it's absolutely true and for me the
other big part was my my cheering Squad
having an accountability partner as a
single woman was very important because
when my ex and I were doing it together
we were accountability Partners right
but on my own I mean I've got four
amazing accountability Partners my
parents my sister and brother-in-law
they are cheering me on you know really
helped when I had questions of like hey
should I do this
um you know because I am a free spirit I
like to spend my money yeah so they
would help me rein that in a ton yeah
well good for you for getting that
because a lot of people don't because
it's awkward or because they really
don't want the accountability they may
say they do but they don't really and
you did and you got it so well done yeah
what was the hardest part of this
journey I know you worked a lot of hours
is there a moment where you can look
back on this journey and go this was
really really tough but I pushed through
and on the other side now I'm glad I did
absolutely when I had gotten that second
job I so my full-time job I work the
closing shift so I'm at work until 10
30. and my my part-time job I was
working 5 a.m to 9 A.M wow so that was
really rough I'd go to work in the
morning come home take a nap eat get
ready for work and go again so about
probably halfway through that it was I
was exhausted I was really ready to be
done but I wasn't I wasn't done with the
debt yet and so I I had struggled there
were some some weeks that it was like
I'm just gonna do my minimum 12 hours at
my second job and then there was like
okay I want to be done which means I
have to work more yeah yeah but for
short term yeah short-term sacrifice to
be in this position now yeah love that
so so good and you got you mentioned
those those cheerleaders those
accountability folks they're with you I
want to point out they're sitting just
to your right as we look at you through
the window and they've all got t-shirts
and you were kind of the inspiration
behind that yours says be weird for
those that can't see the YouTube channel
you know and and so uh you know that's
really really exciting too to kind of be
here with them they're here today
they're going to celebrate with you
absolutely yeah it's total you know
family effort
um like I said they're all out of debt
as well so we've each got individually
something different on our shirts
um but and then on the back of it it
says debt is a thing of my past so it's
yeah it's been a lot of fun well you've
been through a lot yep not just the that
free Journey but uh the relationship
break and I know that that has got to be
wild just to kind of deal with the
newness of that and you're just so
strong yeah and uh you're inspiring a
lot of people uh right now and so we are
so grateful one of the things we want to
do for you we've got a copy of Dave's
book the Legacy Journey uh which is
that's the next step for you to live and
give of like no one else and then we're
also going to give you copy of Dave's
book Total Money Makeover for you to
gift to somebody else that you think uh
think might need that so we want to give
that to you so you're ready to go it's
been a journey you're ready to go I am
okay good well you can tell all right so
here it is Lindsay from Sacramento
California she paid off twenty four
thousand dollars in 17 and a half months
making twenty seven thousand to thirty
seven thousand dollars Lindsay take it
away let's hear your debt free scream
three two one I'm Deb free
there it is she did it Mom dad's just
looking on they all got the theme
t-shirts Christy that's pretty cool
stuff I love it I love it and and what
an important time in her life to do this
it would have been so easy to go through
that divorce to go through one of the
hardest things I'm sure she's ever gone
through and then just kind of just kind
of take your foot off the gas curl up in
the fetal position be like I just want
to be sad for a few years and just kind
of do what I want to buy a bunch more
therapy spending yeah I mean seriously
like I mean that would be a very normal
way to cope with that and instead she
channeled that energy channeled that
motivation and was like I'm gonna I'm
gonna give myself a fresh start I'm
gonna tackle this myself I'm gonna take
care of it I'm going to take
responsibility for what is mine and get
it out of here and as a result all of
the fruits of her hard work have paid
off and she's standing there debt free
with a whole whole new chapter in front
of her and all the options in the world
man what what an impressive impressive
woman she is the best is yet to come if
you're out there in that situation you
can do it Lindsay did it
stay with it it's always worth it that's
right my colleague is Christy Wright I'm
Ken Coleman you're listening to the
Ramsay show don't move more coming right
up
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back America you are listening
to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman I'm
joined here in Studio by my colleague
Christy Wright as we take your questions
it is a toll-free call Triple eight
eight two five five two two five
blinds.com
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure pick the wrong color which by
the way Christy that would be me if
it'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
Ramsey to get the best deal
today's question comes from Noah in
Colorado my husband and I have two young
kids we have no debt and make about 200
000 between the two of us for the first
time in our lives we make enough to live
comfortably and safe for retirement
we've gone from 25 000 to 300 000 in
savings over the last three years my
primary job is done remote and I'm
considering taking on a second remote
job which would add about a hundred
twenty thousand dollars in income I do
not want to work more hours but I
believe I can work more efficiently and
get good results I want to do this so we
can have the option to retire early and
spend more time with our kids is having
two remote jobs
at the same time unethical and am i
setting myself up for failure Christy I
love this question because I actually
reported on this on the Ken Coleman show
this week this is a new thing there is a
huge movement of people that are working
two remote jobs at the same time it's
happening more and more so the answer
the question is uh it is unethical it is
wrong if both companies aren't aware of
it now if for some crazy strange reason
both companies are going yeah we're fine
with you knocking down uh salaries or
whatever the pay is for two companies uh
then of course it's okay but for one to
not know about the other uh yeah I don't
think that's right I don't at all even
though it's doable and people are doing
it okay here's what I heard in this
question and tell me if maybe I'm I'm
reading into it here's what I heard
they said I don't want to work more
hours
yeah but I believe I could work more
efficiently so so if you asked me I
didn't know about that study and I know
you're important move your state is it
unethical to have two jobs no people
have two jobs all the time whether
they're remote or out in the workforce
but you have to physically be present
and work those hours right like you have
to actually do those hours
if you're planning to work from home and
not actually work those hours and just
collect the check then of course that's
ethical regardless of the other company
because you're planning to collect money
for work you're planning to not do
that's my point so this is not possible
no no no now let me let's use an analogy
here well but it is if you work if you
work 80 hours a week I mean if you if
you work the the hours and the companies
know that I don't know why you couldn't
do it but I know but that's what I said
the companies have got to know yeah if
the company so right but even if the
companies know you still have to
actually work the hours yeah and you you
cannot imagine that you're just not
gonna work yeah and are going to collect
a paycheck let me give you an example so
Ken when I um uh registered for my first
Seminary class this summer it said you
know the the curriculum said every class
is requires about 15 hours a week and in
my mind I'm going like
does it but does it could I maybe get
this done in like I don't know seven to
eight like that was mine no Ken it's
really 15 hours a week so like it's
forced me to make time in my schedule
for this as much as I would love for it
to only be seven hours
to Noah If this job says it's a 40 hour
a week job then unless you want to work
40 hours then yes it's unethical but
you're not gonna because you're asking
if you can basically not work those
hours they're asking for that is lying
and cheating and stealing and yes it's
lying but if you want to work those 40
hours and you want to work 80 hours a
week by all means take that second job
as long as they know yeah which she's
gonna do so that's why I said what I
said these people are doing this Christy
it's crazy there's these people online
and they're like encouraging people to
do this and they're cheating companies
they're like taking two full-time jobs
and not working full-time because
they're not they're at home it's
unbelievable well I can't believe it but
it's but it's real because here's the
deal this is what remote work does I'm
not anti-remote work but with without
accountability you can want someone to
work 40 hours a week but they could
probably do it in 20.
well that's a leadership problem
you don't disagree with me on this I
know you I don't disagree nobody's got
to know about it
100 but I'm saying if if they say we
have a a position there's a 40 hour
position we're going to give you three
minutes of work well then you don't have
a full-time position you need to fix
your position
people are not telling both companies
that they're knocking down right double
the salary so it is this is a thing
though this is not a rare question as
well is what I'm pointing well but then
it's good that you point that out
because we need to take we need people
to be very clear on our stance if you
plan to work two remote jobs and not
work the hours required by two remote
jobs that both jobs know about you are
lying cheating and stealing you're a lot
by definition you're a liar yeah so I
just want to go ahead and be clear so
everyone knows but if you want to work
both those jobs all the hours tell both
jobs sure collect both salaries if you
do the work for it otherwise you're
lying yep okay absolutely man we're on
the same page there yeah yeah
but I get why people are doing it
because again there's no oversight how
do they get away with that though like
how do they have because there's no
oversight there's no you're not in an
office where somebody can see what
you're doing and so you're doing the
emails you're doing the meetings is it
is it just they don't have 40 hours
worth of deliverables to where anybody
would know oh they're slipping on their
work I just can't imagine yeah so
there's just not the work is not
they're able to get the job done to the
point that their leadership isn't firing
them over at least at this point now
again this is a relatively new
phenomenon there's two dudes who went
online and created a whole website I
don't want to give them any luck yeah
yeah because I don't like where it's
going right the bottom line is is if if
you can get away with it but like she
said at the last part of the question is
it unethical yes based on what we said
and B uh am i setting myself up for
failure yeah
yeah personally would you would you go
by the way they make 300 000 excuse me
they make two hundred thousand dollars I
mean they've got 300 000 in savings
relax would you want would you go get
two full-time jobs in person if you
wouldn't then you don't need to take two
and and how that's exactly the point and
she would but there's people that work
two full-time jobs all the time that's
fine if you want to do it but I have no
problem with that but as long as you're
you are fulfilling what is required of
you right right yeah right stuff all
right we've beat that horse too Oblivion
well I just I think it's good to call
out because I didn't realize what I
didn't realize this was a thing oh it's
happening but in addition to the fact
that it's a thing that yeah your
characters at stake here your integrity
your character your yeah yeah let's go
to Andrea who joins us in Tucson Arizona
Andrea how can we help
um but I am only making about 21
000 and so for me to invest 15 of my
income I wouldn't be able to afford my
four walls
so I'm kind of at the point where I want
to invest in my retirement but at the
same time graduate school is taking up
all of my time and is it bad not to
invest in my retirement right now
because I'm investing in my future no
your future is absolutely the priority
here you're a little bit different
situation Andrea because you're a
college student and so of course you
would always need to take care of your
four walls first anyway but the goal
would be that later in life you can take
care of the four walls and invest in
baby step four but right now your
college education is the priority so not
only do you want to cover your four
walls you want to have some cushion
between you and any life transitions so
whether that's next semester's tuition
books Transportation all that stuff so
no you that is investing right now if
you cannot afford it above and beyond
your your regular expenses is not a
priority for you and that's okay because
it will be when you get to that stage
when when you're out of college when you
can afford that on top of your four
walls that'll be the time to start that
and you're still so young you will still
be starting investing very early so
don't be discouraged by losing time
there because because you you said it
perfectly you're investing in your
future and that's what you should be
doing as a college student so no you're
doing great yeah love that question and
you know you know the reality is is that
so many young people don't realize how
much progress they're gonna make even if
they're coming out of grad school right
they'll be like oh it's no I mean if
you're starting to invest in your
mid-20s and you do it the way Ramsey
solution tells you do I mean it's going
to be unbelievable I just read an
article today 401ks Christy all-time
high oh awesome so you know when we talk
about just stay on the roller coaster
ride don't freak out
um I mean the bottom line is is you're
going to make up a lot of ground so I
love that advice but it makes good sense
I love the question I love what she's
thinking about that yeah unbelievable
yeah if you're in college and you're
debt free and your priority is staying
debt free paying for for college then
right there you're ahead of the vast
majority of college students who are who
are deeply in debt with student loans or
credit card debt or whatever so you're
doing great Andrea you're doing awesome
stay on that track get through this this
college education and then you can start
looking at investing when you've got
more income to do so yeah I can't
believe the hour is done goes by fast
time flies when you're having fun fun
Friday and we are having fun hey I want
to thank our producer Ben and Hill I
want to thank our associate producer and
call screener Kelly Daniel and my
colleague Christy Wright always fun to
be with you and America thank you you
are the reason we do the show this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Kelly associate producer for
the Ramsey show this episode is over but
if you heard about an event product or
service and didn't have a chance to
write it down don't worry we list
everything you've heard about during
this episode of the podcast show notes
section or head to the ramsayshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
foreign
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the Dollar
Car Rental Studio this is the Ramsey
Show it's where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life I'm
Ken Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Christy Wright the phone number to jump
in on the conversation is triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and we will dive in we're going to break
it down we're going to help you see that
there is hope we're going to help you
see that there's a clear path of actions
to be able to move forward whether
you're talking about your work getting a
bigger shovel you're talking about
getting time back in your life you're
talking about uh marriage and
relationship stuff around money you're
talking about toxic leadership or you
want to lead better I mean it's all up
for conversation triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to Dana
who's going to join us in Kansas City
Dana how can we help
hey Ken and Kirsty how are you what's
going on
oh I'm just sitting here racking my
brain trying to figure out whenever I
need to start my business all right well
I like this question what's going on
with the what's the situation around it
well so right now I'm an outside
salesperson uh for a night National pest
control company I do really well I enjoy
my job uh but there's sometimes I kind
of feel like a cage animal uh so I am
looking at starting my own landscaping
lawn care business I was that little kid
that you saw you know 10 12 years old
not there with a push mower
shoveling snow doing all that stuff
whenever I was a little kid and that
always has intrigued me so I'm looking
at doing that but right now we're in the
middle of baby stuff too and so I'm
trying to figure out if I need to pump
the brakes or just get on the
accelerator a little bit more well I've
got a couple follow-up questions
um because I think that you can do it
now but we just need to figure out the
numbers so how much debt do you have uh
so right now we're at 23 000. okay and
do you have a reasonable level of
equipment a mower a weed eater the basic
you know leaf blower the basics you'd
need to start at least just cutting
yards don't think fancy Landscaping this
is not the Cadillac version of your
dream idea business but do you have
something to start getting started
so right now no I'd be starting from
scratch that being said I do have a paid
off vehicle that I would be able to sell
and cash flow
yeah a truck a trailer Mower and all
that would that be one of your primary
vehicles or something that's uh not
going to hold you back as far as normal
Transportation so I have a company
provided vehicle as of right now
in August this would be a startup at the
soonest and the spring of this upcoming
year how much could you get for that uh
vehicle
I'm thinking somewhere between nine to
ten
I'm gonna challenge you for a second
why wouldn't you sell that vehicle now
and put it to the 23 in debt and fast
forward this deal this whole journey and
that that's the other path that I've
been trying to Rack my brain on
is I can sell that I could put the
business on hold for another year it's
my work isn't
flight driving me out and like I hate my
job it's nothing like that sure what do
you mean feel like there's something
missing sure what do you make
uh so right now I'm sitting around 70
gross for the year so if you put 10
seconds
yeah how how fast would you pay off the
debt what's your debt payoff date
um as of right now without selling this
but right now we're looking at the end
of January this upcoming year oh dude I
sell a car today
um because right now let me tell you why
because now is is probably the highest
amount of money you're going to get for
that vehicle I mean we're at an
unbelievable used price used car premium
right now so I would sell that now and
cut this debt uh almost in half not
quite and then you're going to fast
forward everything and do the lawn care
and Landscaping that that opportunity is
not going away that's what I would do
Christy do you see anything with that no
I mean the fact that you're going to get
out of debt so soon this is not even a
question because I misunderstood I
thought your question was can I start
the business in baby step two which if
you can turn a profit quickly it is okay
to start a business in baby step two
that's why I was trying to help you
figure out how to do that but you just
told me you're gonna be out of debt in
January you wouldn't want to start the
business until March anyway so starting
in maybe step two is not even a question
and the great news is you're going to
have between January and March to save
up a little cash to maybe get you a
mower get a couple things that you need
and then you start putting business
cards in mailboxes you start talking to
your neighbors you start I mean as the
spring is coming you know leaves are
getting in the trees you're talking to
people people when that that season is
ramping up and you're getting that
business going but still Dana I want you
to get it started on the side do not
walk away from your steady paycheck even
though you're out of debt you're going
to build this business up on the side
which is a perfect business to do on the
side you can do this in the evenings on
the weekends until the business can
support you and then when the business
can support you financially the money's
actually there and think consider the
seasonality consider consider the winter
in your projections and then you're
ready to stop that so that's what you're
going to do you're going to get out of
debt first you're going to build up the
business marketing and demand and get
your equipment in the spring you're
going to start your business in the
spring on the side Build It Up all
summer and then we'll see how that goes
before you're ready to walk away from
your full-time job but I think that's an
awesome timeline I think you can totally
do it that's a very safe way to do it
and it's a very soon way to do it you're
doing it safely but it's also pretty
quick so that's exciting yeah and and
I'm glad that we got this call because I
think when people when they realize that
I don't have to walk away from the day
job and it's just it's it's just not
necessary it's a false narrative I can
start as you say small and grow slow and
certainly in a landscaping once he gets
out of debt gets that emergency fund
going he can cash flow one machine right
and he starts taking on two three four
yards and all of a sudden we just stack
that money and and I get this call all
the time of the Cancun show people say
well Ken when's the right time to move
to my side tussle full time and I go
it's not a time it's not it's not a time
question it's a math question yes
once you've got and I prefer six months
of your income in your company your side
hustle at least six months personally
and again this is conservative I'd like
to have 12 months of my salary before
I'm gonna walk but six months is
probably fine if you got a pipeline if
you got customers but it becomes a math
thing well once once I see that the math
is there that I'm making as much or more
uh or if it's just a little less but
with a slight budget adjustment it's a
no-brainer well another thing though is
that I think people forget about is that
path is not as glamorous it's not as
like wow like you're you're not having
this Jerry Maguire moment where you grab
the goldfish with me it's like that
seems so cool in the movies and in real
life it's terrifying you don't have an
income and you look crazy because you
are so instead do the less impressive
less Hollywood version where you start
on the side you're Scrappy you work
nights you work weekends you're tired
feels like you're working two times two
full-time jobs because you are you build
it up on the side to where it can
financially support you and then it's
not this terrifying Leaf it's the next
logical step we don't want you to take
leaps take steps
Jerry Maguire trivia real quick before
we go to break do you know how much the
human head weighs eight pounds is that
right I can't remember is that right did
I get it yeah
that's one of the greatest lines in
Jeremy McGuire the little dude in the
car great job
I love that it's so good all right folks
we're having a lot of fun don't move
more of your calls coming right up this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Chrissy Wright and we are here together
this hour to take your calls Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
it's toll-free triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to
Indianapolis Indiana now where Elizabeth
joins us Elizabeth how can we help
hi Ken and Christy my question is a
career line it boils down to the
opposite of your new book title Ken I
went from purpose to just a paycheck in
my job
um I'm looking for some advice four
weeks ago I left the job but I really
enjoyed
um for a new opportunity that I was
excited about with a bigger paycheck but
in just that short amount of time I've
discovered that I feel no missional
behind the work that I'm doing every day
and when that happened and you read that
the eight hour work day suddenly becomes
a really really long one yes
um but I left on excellent terms with my
former company I actually learned that I
have the chance to go back in a new role
that I think I would once again feel a
lot of excitement and passion about but
I'm not sure what the responsible way is
to handle that given that I just started
with this new company so I would
appreciate your perspective on that yeah
first of all don't overthink this you're
not a bad person you are not a bad
person you made it to decision that a
lot of human beings have made and it
feels really good by the way when we get
an opportunity for a promotion it also
comes with a bigger paycheck so let's
just let's take all the guilt and let's
just throw it aside because it's a very
normal response there's nothing wrong
with you and you're not a flake or some
type of evil person because you're going
to do what you what I'm going to tell
you to do which is you got to go sit
down with your first of all I'd accept
the new position at the old company and
I do it with some humility and go hey I
chase the paycheck I am beyond grateful
to have this opportunity to me that's a
no-brainer so except the old one uh go
back to the old company except that now
go to the new folks and say Hey listen
uh I'm really sorry
this is a difficult conversation for me
uh and I'm grateful that you offered me
a promotion uh to take this job
opportunity four weeks ago and I took it
and uh I realized that it's not right
for me and you can use you know the
words I use you've been listening to my
show I can tell that just talk about
passion and Mission and go here's the
deal I'm stealing from you if I stay
here a day longer now here's the deal
it doesn't mean they're gonna go oh well
thank you Elizabeth you are so nice to
tell us this they may be pissed off
right okay that's just the reality of
the world we live in but you still got
to be honest you still got to tell them
what's right that's the honorable thing
to do and say Hey I want to leave well
whatever that looks like for you all I
want to help with the transition I am
really really sorry but I'm doing this
now because if I delay this it's not
going to be good for me or for you and
again I'm sorry to put you in this
position but I gotta own it I got to be
a big girl right now but don't you know
fall on a sword like you're a bad person
just kind of own that situation and then
I would move on I'll give you an example
of how this has happened in the Sports
World before
uh there's a guy by the name of Billy
Donovan long time uh college basketball
coach a long time uh coaches won two
national titles at the University of
Florida back to back and he got
approached after the second Title by the
Orlando Magic an NBA team and he
begrudgingly kind of listened to him and
then decided he was going to take the
job Christy well uh so he takes it and
he goes to the whole press conference
cries leaving Florida a beautiful
special place in my life and goes to
Orlando does the press conference there
wakes up two days later and tells his
wife this is the wrong move
now this is a big deal yeah this guy's
going to be a Hall of Fame yeah and uh
but he owned it and he and it was a big
deal got criticized got crushed in the
media by a lot of people but uh he stood
up and said hey I made the wrong
decision yeah I got I got enticed by the
opportunity to be in the National
Basketball Association something I've
always dreamed of doing it's not right I
belong back at Florida and he went back
so this is tough this is not going to be
an easy conversation but I think she's
got to do it but well she does and what
I love about your advice to her that is
so key any time what even if you're a
leader let's say there's someone
listening right now you're a leader
you're a business owner and you have
um made a mistake in your leadership
whatever that looks like the key is
owning it period owning it and so when
you go Elizabeth and you have this
conversation you just say exactly like
Ken said you say I'm really sorry I made
a mistake and that's like I made a
mistake people will respect you for just
owning that and the other thing I don't
know what this new company is like if
they have a 90-day policy then most
companies expect that in the first 90
days they're going to figure out if
you're the right fit for the position
and you're going to figure out if
they're right for you and so it is so
great that you're finding this out now
it's not like you you know you're six
months in and they're really starting to
put some workload on you and then you
pull out they have you haven't even done
anything yet I mean really like you have
not like got so integrated into this
company they can't stand to not have you
no no this is this is fine you're going
to do this and you're gonna feel such
relief afterwards because you're going
to be back where you need to be doing
the right thing it's just going to take
a hard conversation between now and then
and the key is humility and owning it
and you're going to do that so yeah you
definitely should do it yeah and just a
real quick warning for folks because a
lot of people make this decision when we
get a new opportunity two things are
happening okay one we feel good feels
good to be wanted by somebody else yes
hey throw our shoulders back feels good
somebody wants me second thing that
happens is is when there's more zeros or
there's more money involved it all of a
sudden just becomes a this is the right
thing to do this is a good decision so I
feel good and it must be good because
it's more money and that's a trap so
just be careful that I have more of
these calls than you could possibly
imagine on this and uh really proud of
you though for owning this Elizabeth and
your best days are ahead let's go to Los
Angeles California now where Elmer joins
us Elmer how can we help
what's up I just want to say I'm a long
time this year and first time caller oh
thank you
yeah I was hoping to speak with Mr
Ramsey himself but you guys can I just
tell you Elmer that I gotta tell you I
understand I would be disappointed if I
were you as well but let me tell you
something Christy can handle this Elmer
let me tell you you give it a shot to
you and the rest of America would rather
Dave to be sitting in these days yeah we
can handle it thank you for your honor
we are very aware and we're still here
for you what's your question
okay so um I've been better dealing with
students that's the only debt I have you
know
um
anyways
I took care of 27
000 out of a private student debt okay I
took care of that and then you know even
after covid I I killed it in December
2020. okay
now now I'm trying to battle the big
hairy monster of the federal student
that catches a 78k okay
now my job situation with my my income
has changed because I'm not earning the
same amount that I was
and um are you earning more or less
you're way less way less
so now
um
I need to attack this because it's not
going away and
we all know that the government's not
going to help at all watch your income
go down
uh I left the country I was working at
and now I returned back to States
because of my wife who's uh who's
working on the immigration process okay
what's your income right now
wow uh I would say it's at 21
000. okay and 1K a year so let me jump
in here
so Elmer listen to me right now we have
10.1 million jobs available in the
United States 10.1 million available
okay companies are paying signing
bonuses companies are offering tuition
assistance or full blown tuition what
did you do in a pre in that other
country what kind of work were you doing
I was a foreign English instructor okay
let me just tell you something I want to
give it to Chrissy to talk to you about
the debt snowball but for you to assume
that you can't make more than 21 000 in
this economy let me just tell you
something people are desperate for
workers you need to get back to work as
a part of this process let's get the
income up that that is the answer I mean
Elmer that is the answer you're living
in La you can't be okay with 21 000 and
there is no strategy to pay off that 78
000 on 21 000 while living in La I don't
know how you're eating honestly so you
have got to get your income up that
might be a second job third job might be
doing freelance English teaching it
might be getting a completely different
job with a promotion with the signing
bonus today you're searching jobs today
your debt payoff plan is getting your
income up that is the only way you're
going to do this and you can do it but
it's going to take a different strategy
than you had before to get that income
back up yeah it's one of the hottest job
markets that we've ever seen in fact
folks there are more jobs available now
than there were in February of 2020
which was the previous high it's
unbelievable if you just have a pulse
and you'll show up with a smile
you can make really good money in
America right now go to work this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
joined by my colleague Christy Wright
the phone number to jump in on the
conversation is triple eight eight two
five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five okay
have you ever made a dumb decision with
zeros on the end because you didn't do
your research I have so
um you know telling you don't be ashamed
most people make choices based on
feelings or opinions especially when
they're buying a house but when it comes
to the real estate market feelings are
not your friend facts are so check your
facts find out what you can actually
afford research what's trending in home
prices talk to a reputable real estate
Pro in your area never buy a house
without the fax again go to
ramsesolutions.com
agent that's ramsaysolutions.com agent
and get an agent who will help you make
smart decisions that's
ramseysolutions.com slash agent all
right let's go now to Pensacola Florida
where Nathan joins us Nathan how can we
help
you I love the show
I recently retired from the military and
uh I've got a new uh new job but it
doesn't pay a lot right now at the
moment it's going to pay more uh in the
coming years but right now it's not
paying a lot so we're kind of I wouldn't
say on a super fixed income but we're
kind of on a fixed income my question
will be uh I stopped making any kind of
investment uh contributions when I
retired from the military I was making a
seven percent contribution automatically
and that's done really well it's
continuing to grow but my question will
be should I be taking some of my
military retirement money and investing
that as well
based on our income right now now we're
doing well otherwise we've got a lot of
equity in our home we've got a lot of
mutual fund cash that's in in both
mutual funds
um and then we've also got of course
IRAs and Roth IRAs and such so we're
doing really well if we did nothing else
in our life right now we would we would
live comfortably but my question would
be is there more than I should be doing
with that retirement my money
um besides just kind of bringing into
account and paying off the bills yeah so
what is your income from your well first
of all thank you for your service what's
your income from your military
retirement
so uh with a disability and the
retirement
um I'm about 7 500 a month okay and you
you're saying you don't need that to
live on because with the job that you
have now you can live on that
yes okay
and then what are you contributing
currently to your retirement not Nelson
right now okay
yes yes I would use your income that you
don't need to contribute to your
retirement but what you want to do is
you want to sit down with an investment
professional because if you want to end
up transferring any of this and they can
help you with the tax implications in
terms of what to move where you want to
sit down with a really good investment
professional they could actually walk
you through this but you can and should
be investing right now since you have
the income to do it if you didn't have
the income then that would be one thing
but you have it and so yeah Nate that I
would I would sit down with one of our
endorsed local providers one of our
investment professionals and get them to
walk you through where to put it how
much to contribute it sounds like you
should be able to to be continuing to
contribute your 15 percent it's just
coming from a different place it's not
coming from your traditional job it's
just a little bit of different situation
because you're in retirement one but
actively working in another so you just
want to sit down with someone to walk
you through that but yeah you can and
should be contributing now let's go to
Aaron now in Richmond Virginia Aaron how
can we help
hey yeah it's a long time listener of
course I'm caller awesome um
so just trying to figure out uh so my
wife basically is not on board with
trying to pay off debt
um definitely trying I'm that's what I'm
my goal is to pay off there we have a
separate debt we have separate bank
accounts and separate everything else
um just because we both been uh Burns in
the past by a former uh spouses
um so just trying to figure out a way to
get her on board to pay down this debt
wow well well well well well well well
well well Aaron where do we start on
this listen
um so this is actually not a question
about paying down debt at all because
what you said is actually the most
important piece of this that you just
flew by which is we've been burned in
the past so y'all have been burned in
the past and so you're not trusting so
you have separate bank accounts so you
have separate goals
and and that is affecting everything
with your finances so actually to me and
actually that's the bigger problem I I
would actually uh I I would care to fix
that more than fix the who's paying down
what debt win I I care about you getting
debt free but I think the fact that you
don't trust each other in your marriage
is a way way bigger problem and so I it
the best thing I could advise you to do
in in that sense and maybe it's maybe
you guys can work it out on your own
with just some conversations but I think
even just a counselor or someone in your
church for you guys to work through
those fears because listen you're not
dating you're married and it is an
oxymoron to be married to someone you
don't trust the trust is the foundation
of marriage and so for you guys to fix
the trust issue we'll fix the bank
account issue and then you can talk to
you know her about Mutual goals I mean
to me that is so secondary to the trust
because you'll never be able to to get
her on board as you say or even get on
the same page with goals when you all
have separate bank accounts but the
foundation of the separate bank accounts
is a lack of trust does that make sense
yeah that makes sense how long have you
guys been married just gonna ask that
thank you yeah sure about three yeah
okay and have you ever even discussed
the idea of combining accounts
we have discussed the idea before in the
past uh basically comes down to that uh
yeah I don't think either one of us are
are 100 trusting I I wouldn't I'm
willing to put you know to use her bank
accounts he wanted to like it doesn't
really matter to me but uh yeah I just
don't know she's not really down with
that you know because she doesn't want
to to be like hey I'm using my money or
I'm using your money I'm like no it
would be our money together is she more
of the Spender
oh most definitely yeah yeah she didn't
want you telling her what to do that's
the problem she doesn't want you seeing
what she's spending things on and she
didn't want to have anybody to report to
and listen she got married she's got to
get over that yeah hold on hold on a
second all right this is great because
actually I'm gonna come at you Aaron you
know you just said a second ago that
you're like neither one of us are there
so I got to tell you something you might
need to show her some trust before you
can ask her to show you some trust I I
you know I heard just as much fear out
of you am I right
yeah I would say so yeah so but he said
he's willing to share bank accounts and
I know but my point is is he's got to
make that step I love that I love that
he said that but it's like you got to do
something about that and you got to say
here's the deal but I think back to what
Christy said is absolutely right this is
a counseling deal you guys got to really
get over some of the stuff that that by
the way is very real and raw I mean I
don't want in any way minimize it no but
Aaron that's awesome both are hurting
and you need to get with approach I'd
stop having the conversation about
budgets and sharing accounts and just go
hey you know what
I think we just got to heal from our
past hurts and let's help each other
heal well and the thing Aaron is that
that lack of trust you're seeing it your
bank accounts and this symptom at the
surface but it is it is pouring into
more aspects of your marriage than you
can possibly realize and I don't even
have to know you guys to know that
because trust is so foundational and so
if you guys each have your individual
wounds and you won't let that other
person in whether it's from a bank
account standpoint or whatever the bank
account's a great tangible example but
what you're doing is you're punishing
your spouse for your ex-spouses mistakes
and she's punishing you and you're
punishing her and what's happening is
it's putting a huge wedge in your
marriage where y'all can't make progress
not just financially but in more aspects
of your marriage than you realize
because of that lack of trust because of
that oh well well he burned me or she
Burns me and you can't you can't come
into this part of my life that there
there is that is a recipe for disaster
in marriage and so I just want to
encourage you to get with a counselor or
one of the one of the foundational
things you'll talk about is trust but
one of the first steps of that would be
to combine your bank accounts and then
speak into goals together and don't
don't even try to get her on board with
a debt debt until you fix this because
you haven't earned the right to talk
about debt if you don't even have the
foundation of trust but get that fixed
and then you can talk about the bank
accounts the goals and the debts and
you'll get there but you might need a
little outside Health to get it and
that's okay that is a good thing help is
a good thing Matt and I get help with
things we need help with it is a good
thing you can do it absolutely start
trusting her lead the way be the leader
here and please go see a professional
good stuff thank you so much for the
call fight for this fight hard for your
marriage it's worth it all right don't
move more of your calls coming up this
is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back America you are listening
to the Ramsey show where we talk about
your life your money your work your time
your health we're thrilled to have you
I'm Ken Coleman joined by Christy Wright
my colleague
today's scripture of the day in the same
way you judge others you will be judged
and with the measure you use it will be
measured to you Matthew 7 2. our quote
today comes from Dale Carnegie any fool
can criticize condemn and complain and
most fools do but it takes character and
self-control to be understanding and
forgiving well that's interesting that
Carnegie said that because it feels like
that'd be great advice for anybody going
on social media today yeah that's a fact
takes a long fool can get behind a
keyboard and fire a dart that's right
but they never say it to you in person
Christy that's right although you know
we had a fun moment this hour can we
revisit it please it was your favorite
moment oh which one I have so many Earl
was it Earl
he called Elmer thank you oops oh well
it's perfect we take the call
Elmer how can we help very nice guy
uh slow pace and with a little bit of uh
disappointment he said well I was
actually hoping to talk today
at which point I should have said well
you know what we were actually looking
forward to talking to somebody else
besides you no I can't listen can we
tell can we tell America what happens in
the lobby in between segments I'm so
glad you're gonna do this because this
is very awkward for me and now we get to
therapeutically share it listen here's
the thing about Enneagram eights if
there's awkwardness we just bulldoze
straight into it yeah
like we're just gonna call it out right
so um wait a second hold on are you an
eight or a three an eight buy the book
eight yeah eight Wing seven all right
we'll talk about it I'll figure okay
great
um so you guys don't know this but here
at our lobby there is our debt free
stage you've seen this probably if you
watch us on YouTube and people come in
well in between the breaks even when
we're not having debt-free screams we
have people that come here and they line
up and uh we go out uh us together if
it's us hosting together well they line
up the line up to meet Dave sure they do
um and get their books signed yeah
that's the and get a pick and it's fine
we get pictures all the things well
since we've been hosting the Ramsay
personalities with Dave we go out with
him yeah um because that's what we're
told to do yes
Fallen told on out there and uh here's
what happens so Dave goes first he's on
the right side of the stage if you're
facing the stage we're on the left side
of the stage and if you could see me on
YouTube man y'all people give us such a
hard shoulder they move so far away from
us that you're like I'm not even gonna
try to be in the picture because you
know they're cropping us out like as
soon as they get home they're they're
creeping us out like we were never there
and they got their picture with this is
my personal favorite so my personal
favorite is Dave goes out first and and
they greet him and then and then then I
do this number I stick my hand out hot
and they're they're talking to Dave they
do this where they curl around and I do
this
if y'all the old hand to the hair move
you know what I mean no I it's not all
the time but some of the time it is it
is it is it is and we're and we don't
fight it like I will deliberately move
away from people so that they can crop
me and he's a legend I want to help him
out like a legend he's an icon we get it
but it was really refreshing honestly
and he wasn't being mean not at all yeah
I just want to say Omer I agree with you
I know I'm so sorry no one's more aware
of that than these two people in these
seats right now we get it we get it we
get it you tuned in today and Dave's not
here but we can still help you and we
did I mean we're here and we're gonna be
here whether you like it or not so yeah
yeah yeah there is that that is
absolutely true and Dave will insists
were in the picture whether you like it
or not but we will scooch away so you
can crop us out we are here for you yeah
that's the deal but people say you know
what's it like work every day you know
what it really is amazing because the
guy is he's the real deal and uh he he
loves it he loves doing this because
he's coaching people up so we always
love being with him so here we go uh now
that we just owned all that and it's
okay folks you don't have to be excited
about taking a picture with us it's not
gonna hurt her feelings we get it uh
let's go to Wyatt in which taught Kansas
Wyatt how can we help
good how are you oh we're having a blast
can you tell what's going on
about 120 000 a year oh wow okay what do
you do I
I work at a Refinery nice
and I have been uh putting my money in
my 401k I have about a hundred thousand
in there nice and I was wondering would
it be smart to continue doing that or
should I start putting money into a Roth
IRA instead how much are you investing
right now as a percentage
16 and then the company matches six yeah
okay well and at that income why you're
maxing out on your 401k
right yeah yeah so yeah you need to be
uh continuing to invest great job
absolutely so I'm guessing you don't
have any debt
oh wow
he did that was sneaky what I see what
you did there well listen you're doing a
lot of things right but let's talk about
maybe some areas that can be improved
not investing but the debt what debt do
you have
I have a truck that I owe 15 000 on okay
anything else I have a house that I owe
85 000 on okay well aside from the house
just the truck is that the only debt you
have other than the house
yep okay we're gonna knock this out
like how quick could you knock it out
uh well I only owe fifteen thousand on
it let me ask another question do you
have how much money you got in savings
right now
foreign
roughly just cash yeah not retirement
just saving I believe six thousand that
I've been putting my money towards other
areas yeah yeah but on that income you
can knock out this debt very fast so I
want you to take 5 000 of your six
thousand pay that on the debt you've got
about 10 left I want you to just for a
few months a couple months few months
pay this debt off okay
um normally what we would do is we would
tell you to pause retirement and you can
do that you can pause retirement in
order to pay this off but honestly you
can get it done in a couple months if
you buckle down a few months and so uh I
don't even know that it's worth it to
pause that in order to you know by the
time it goes into effect or whatever you
could run the numbers and see if it's
worth it to to pause your retirement
investing in order to have that extra
cash but I just want you getting it paid
off quick and at that income you
absolutely should be able to don't
go out to eat don't do anything for just
a couple months get it paid off
um and then from that point uh for your
investing you're you're already maxing
it out uh what you want to do you can
start to put it on the house so you
would walk through baby steps four five
and six four is investing fifteen
percent you're doing that maybe step
five finding kids college do you have
any kids Wyatt
no I do not okay uh so you're not gonna
worry about that we'll just pass one of
that and then you would just put the
rest at the house and you just and this
is a you're taking the foot off of gas a
little bit more than you are in baby
step two where you're sacrificing
everything so it would be a more of a
marathon not a Sprint uh you know you
keep working on the house you can make
extra payments and you can start to pay
that down but Wyatt at your age and with
your income you could have that house
paid for pretty pretty you know in the
next few years if you wanted to and uh
and man then you're just setting
yourself up for such success for
anything else that you want to do
um any other goals you have in life if
you if you get married have a family
those types of things it's just to be so
easy because you don't have any payments
and so how much is your house worth what
you have any idea
um they just appraised it at 170. come
on way to go
22. 22. I got a good deal on it now yeah
but listen right now listen do exactly
what Christy said don't even hesitate
and then knock that house out because
you're going to be and you're you're
gonna be you're gonna be really in
really good shape if a Mrs comes along
and then we want to start a family and
roll that house and that house should
work for for a young couple right and
the kids and well you could be in a
really good situation financially so man
I just want you to be encouraged you're
in great shape do exactly what Christy
said there knock the truck out
um and then walk the rest of the baby
steps out because you or my friend are
way ahead of the game congratulations
yeah you're doing awesome what an
awesome position to be thank you very
much yeah thanks for calling how about
that that is cool 22 year old in the
refinery business you know and again uh
I didn't ask if he went to college but I
mean this is fascinating to to to be
where he's at right now yeah because now
he's going to set himself up who knows
where he's gonna go yeah three years he
wakes up he goes I want to start my own
business so I want to do this I want to
do that and all of that freedom
financially
have Capital to start something yeah I
mean that's unbelievable yeah yeah you
talk to a lot of small business owners I
mean having Financial Freedom to where
you could have some cash and it's a
calculated risk and it doesn't even
affect your income that's a game changer
well not only that but just the thought
that he could be potentially totally
debt free before he ever gets married or
has kids first of all that is real
attractive to a woman for the record
watch out but second of all kids are
expensive and so you've got all this you
have no payments when you're bringing uh
you know a family I mean that's just
amazing well done well done Wyatt
Chrissy Wright always fun nice to be
with you my friend great great job I
want to thank our producer Ben Hill our
associate producer and call screener
Jenna Sears and you America thank you
for joining us this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
Ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell Alexa Google assistant or Siri to
play the Ramsay Show podcast check out
all Ramsay network shows on your smart
speaker today
[Music]